Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
marvel hawkeye deleted scenes alternate ending
video they also had an alternate post credit
scene so i'll explain what's going on there's a
bunch of easter eggs and a bunch of stuff that
got cut from the finale including a bunch of
daredevil stuff if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll be
doing episode videos for the book of boba fett the
mandalorian spin-off series that starts next week
but careful for spoilers from the hawkeye finale
if you haven't seen it yet because we have to talk
about what happened during that to talk about
what didn't happen with all the deleted scenes
and all the other crossovers that they were going
to do for those of you that were holding out for
spider-man crossover i will address that as well
too because there were a lot of people that were
theorizing that because of the timing of the
way they end spider-man no way home there could
have been a spider-man crossover with the hawkeye
finale in rockefeller center here but as far as i
can tell there was never a plan to have spider-man
actually show up during the hawkeye series that's
one of the few things that they had never planned
to do but there were a lot of other characters
that were supposed to show up and there was an
entire post-credit scene that they filmed and then
cut at the last minute so during the actual
hawkeye ending we saw kate bishop versus kingpin
after her mother tried to destroy him with her car
echo tried to kill him with a gunshot for revenge
of her father's death during the five year time
jump we're family sometimes family doesn't see
eye to eye they finally revealed hawkeye's
wife is in fact the mcu mockingbird like we'd
suspected for a couple weeks and then they teased
hawkeye giving kate bishop the hawkeye name like
his whole idea was to just have her call
herself hawkeye since his whole thing since
avengers age of ultron captain america civil
war was he was trying to formally retire from
the avengers and just live with his family
on the farm in the post-credits scene that
we saw was just the rogers captain america
musical full version of the save this city song
they could do that all day just the entire
performance but after the finale was released
they revealed a bunch of these deleted scenes
and storylines from some of the major characters
mostly kingpin related charlie cox's daredevil
kate's mother and hawkeye himself they explained
some of the missing details if you felt like
there were some unanswered questions in the
version that we saw and a lot of the reason why
some of these things got cut and why they just
didn't include them in the finale is the same
as what happened with the wandavision finale
so i actually made this comment on my twitter it
looks like the hawkeye finale got wandavision'd
if you didn't see any of my wandavision alternate
ending deleted scenes videos there was a ton of
stuff that got cut from the wandavision finale
mostly because of all the problems they had
filming it around the virus a lot of actors that
couldn't come back because of travel restrictions
a lot of subplots and storylines they just
completely got rid of so that's kind of what
happened with the hawkeye finale just a lot of
issues filming around the virus and then trying
to just have a cohesive story in general but the
first big thing is charlie cox's matt murdock
and daredevil was originally supposed to have a
cameo scene in the hawkeye series my assumption
is that it would have been in the finale just
a short scene as part of everything that they
were doing with the kingpin storyline giza tease
the kingpin might be ruling over the criminal
underworld of new york city as he said like it's
time to remind people who rules this city he may
have gotten very powerful during that five year
time jump when most of the superheroes had been
snapped but daredevil was on him like red on blood
to make a daredevil metaphor like yes kingpin is a
huge threat now in the mcu confirmed hawkeye kept
calling him the big guy kept talking to his wife
about how dangerous he was and how he was afraid
of him getting involved this whole time but on
the other side of the equation they were going to
let you know that daredevil was on it like don't
worry too much because he's building a new case
against him as matt murdock lawyer during the day
and also at night going after him as daredevil
but the main reason why charlie cox didn't show
up why you didn't see him anywhere is because
of scheduling problems around the other marvel
movies and disney plus shows they were using him
in that's right they wanted daredevil in the mcu
so bad in so many other projects that because of
all the travel restrictions during the virus they
just didn't have time to physically get him to
the location where they were filming the hawkeye
series that is what i call a champagne problem
like we want so much daredevil there's not enough
of him to go around so careful for spoilers from
spider-man no way home if you haven't seen the
movie just because we have to talk about some of
the things that were happening during that movie
with the special cameo scenes a lot of the cool
easter eggs during the movie charlie cox has a
cameo seen as matt murdock lawyer to help peter
parker and the others with their legal problems
regarding mysterio and the drones it was only one
scene was really short but it was amazing the only
real daredevil moment that they had during that
was when he catches the brick without turning his
head and jokes to spider-man that he was able to
do it because he's a really good lawyer and he's
not wrong he is a really good lawyer he just has
incredibly heightened senses and abilities that's
not too unlike the spidey sense it's not quite
the same thing but there are some similarities
charlie cox is also supposed to show up a lot
during the she-hulk episodes which they've been
filming this past year so that's mostly where the
conflict is like them trying to use him in all
these different things during spider-man no way
home during the she-hulk episodes that they've
been busy with but the alternate post-credits
scene that they filmed and ended up not using
was of hawkeye and kingpin they were going to have
a scene after ekko tried to kill kingpin where you
see that he's alive and hawkeye sends him the
ronin sword with a message to leave kate bishop
alone and never come after his family or he'll
come back and kill him hawkeye would come back
to kill kingpin so if you wondered what happened
to the ronin sword after episode 5 because you
don't really see it after hawkeye used it on
echo that's where it went he sent it to kingpin
as a warning there was another deleted scene they
actually posted to their twitter account of him
holding the ronin sword as they were preparing
for the final battle with the tracksuits at
rockefeller center building all the trick arrows
i think the main reason why they didn't use that
kingpin hawkeye post-credit scene is because they
wanted more mystery as to whether or not kingpin
survived echo's gunshot they probably felt like it
would have taken some of the power of that scene
away to show that he was alive five seconds later
like oh she kills him wow that's powerful getting
her revenge even though his fans like we all read
the comics we can read subtext we know that he's
still alive like they wouldn't bring him back for
a couple quick scenes just to kill him right off
so if you're wondering why the hawkeye finale
didn't have a more legit post-credits scene
that's why they filmed it but then just decided
it was too much and swapped in the hawkeye
musical scene at the last second there was also
a whole deleted subplot with kate bishop's mother
they actually confirmed one of my early theories
before the series started so originally i'd guess
they might turn kate bishop's mother into the mcu
version of madame mask because they had this whole
plot during the series about her mother being one
of the secret villains in madame mask is one of
the longtime kate bishop comic book villains so
why not combine those two concepts for a bigger
shengshi type of wtf betrayal reveal like during
shangshi wen wu is this crazy huge mcu villain
that winds up being his parent it just seems like
they were building up to that kind of reveal on
the hawkeye series like oh no my parent is a huge
mcu villain we've had a good relationship haven't
we wilson yes i've never asked questions i've
always done what was told what i'd expect i don't
know why they deleted the subplot maybe there
were too many other scenes they didn't have time
for like flashbacks to explain what she'd been
doing is madam mask and like why she got married
to her father there was that other story moment
in episode five where yelena bulova finds out
about the black widow that had just been living a
normal life like no i wasn't being mind controlled
i've been a mercenary this whole time just living
as a normal housewife so i think that was sort of
meant to play into the kate bishop mother reveal
like she seems like this normal housewife but
she secretly has this really dark past and crazy
skills they also had scenes with qazi in his full
clown makeup from the matte fraction hawk i run
he's called clown in the comics that's his code
name but i'm assuming they got rid of it because
it was also too extra or part of other scenes that
they just cut for time or they didn't want to get
sued by dc and warner brothers for doing a joker
parody because he is kind of a marvel joker parody
as you can see even though his personality in the
comics is very different from the joker so when
i say the hawkeye finale kind of got wandavision
a little there were just a lot of extra scenes
story lines ideas they had when they started
like originally on wandavision they were going
to have doctor strange show up in the finale
and darcy was going to have a lot more scenes in
the finale but she couldn't come back because of
virus travel restrictions so a lot of stuff just
wound up getting left on the cutting room floor
but if they reveal any other big hawkeye deleted
scenes any extra kingpin or daredevil stuff i'll
be sure to include that in future videos both
daredevil and kingpin are coming back during the
echo spinoff series i'll talk more about that
when they reveal more details i also feel like
there were a lot of deleted scenes from the echo
storyline because it felt like she wasn't around
as much as you expected her to be around for a
character that they are doing a whole ass spin-off
for and even though i haven't talked about this
in any of my spider-man videos yet tom holland
did say that he wanted them to use kingpin as a
spider-man villain in future spider-man movies
which they can actually do now and if it wasn't
clear vincent d'onofrio did confirm that his
version of kingpin during hawkeye is meant to be
the same kingpin from the daredevil netflix series
in that the marvel people who wrote his story
try to include as many references and easter
eggs and continuity connections to the daredevil
netflix series like they try to make everything
line up and make sense but when he comes back
during echo and other marvel movies disney
plus series there'll be a lot more connections to
what happened during the netflix daredevil series
he wasn't really around for that many scenes
in hawkeye so it was kind of hard to include
every bit of his backstory but because they just
dropped the doctor strange multiverse of madness
trailer video i'll do much more videos for that
and more spiderman no way home easter eggs so
if you haven't seen the movie yet be sure to go
see it everyone click here for my full hawkeye
episode 6 finale video and click here for my full
doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!